OVER WHO IS IN CHARGE OF THE
CRISIS, IF ANYONE IS.
TOM, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE AND
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT WHO IS
OVERSEEING THIS?
>> I THINK THE BEST THING THAT
COULD HAPPEN TO US IS KAMALA
HARRIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS.
THIS IS THE SAME SENATOR WHO
COMPARED ICE TO THE KKK.
SHE HAS PUT LEGISLATION TO
AWARD ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR.
SHE SUPPORTS SANCTUARY CITIES.
SHE VILIFIED THE BORDER PATROL
SAYING THEY MISTREATED MIGRANTS
DURING THE LAST SURGE.
IT IS OBVIOUS SHE IS THE WRONG
PERSON TO DO THIS.
IF THEY WANT SOMEONE TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE DOING IS TALKING TO
THE CHIEF PATROL AGENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BORDER PATROL WHO
DEALT WITH THIS THIS WHOLE
CAREER.
LET HIM ENFORCE THE LAWS OF THE
COUNTRY AND LET HIM CHANGE THE
POLICIES HE NEEDS TO GET THE
BORDER BACK SECURE.
>> WHO DO YOU THINK IS THE
RIGHT PERSON TO SORT OF OVERSEE
EVERYTHING AT THE VERY BIG
MACRO LEVEL HERE?
WE KNOW CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL PLAYS A BIG PART AS DOES
NOW IN THIS ADMINISTRATION HHS.
IS THERE AN OFFICIAL TO OVERSEE
AND REPORT TO PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> NOT THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THEY HAVE NO INTENTION OF
ENFORCING THE LAW.
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
WE SECURED THE BORDER, ARRESTED
THOSE ENTERING ILLEGALLY.
DETAINED THEM AND GAVE THEM DUE
PROCESS.
90% OF CENTRAL AMERICANS WHO
CLAIM FEAR AT THE BORDER NEVER
GET RELIEF BUT REMOVE ORDERS
AND ICE REMOVED THEM.
WHEN WE ENFORCED THE LAW THE
NUMBERS WENT DOWN ON THE BORDER.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE IT
CLEAR THEY GUTTED ICE TOOK AWAY
90% OF THEIR AUTHORITY.
THE BORDER PATROL INSTEAD OF
HAVING ENFORCEMENT POSTURE
THEY’RE WELCOMING CENTERS
INSTRUCTED TO RELEASE THESE
PEOPLE INTO THE U.S. WITH COVID
SOMETIMES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
DETENTION AND ENFORCEMENT IS NO
LONGER AN OPTION UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> YOU’RE THERE WITH A
DELEGATION OF 17 REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS AND TELL US YOUR
IMPRESSIONS FROM BEING ON THE
GROUND SO FAR AND TELL US THE
MAIN DIFFERENCES YOU SEE, TOM,
BETWEEN NOW TODAY AND THE LAST
TIME YOU WERE AT THIS SPOT ON
THE BORDER.
>> WELL, UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WE HAD ANOTHER
FAMILY SURGE AND STOPPED IT BY
ENFORCING THE LAWS OF THIS
COUNTRY.
NOW I STARTED MY CAREER WITH
THE BORDER PATROL IN 1984.
I SPENT MY ENTIRE CAREER ON
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
I WENT TO A PLACE CALL LA JOLLA
AND I SEE A GROUP OF FAMILY
UNITS BEING DETAINED BY THE
BORDER PATROL.
10 MINUTES ANOTHER 7 AND 8 COME
UP.
LIKE THE MOVIE THE FIELD OF
DREAMS.
INSTEAD OF COMING OUT OF CORN
THEY WERE COMING OUT OF THE
BRUSH TURNING THEMSELVES OVER
TO BORDER PATROL.
WITHIN 10 MINUTES THEY HAD 100
FAMILY UNITS IN CUSTODY.
MORE ACTIVITY DOWN A DIRT ROAD.
THERE IS ANOTHER 100 IN CUSTODY
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
LET ME SAY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING I SAW.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAID THEY
HAVE A HUMANE POLICY.
THE ONLY HUMANITY I SAW AND
COMPASSIONATE WERE THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF BORDER PATROL HUGGING
THE CHILDREN.
A SAW A BIG BORDER PATROL
PERSON TALK TO A 7-YEAR-OLD
GIRL TRYING AND WITHIN A COUPLE
OF MINUTES HE GOT HER THE CRACK
A SMILE.
THEY ARE IN A DIFFICULT
POSITION.
THEIR COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
IT IS A DISGRACE AND
DISRESPECTFUL TO EVERY MAN AND
WOMAN WHO WEARS THE UNIFORM
THAT SAVED OVER 4,000 MIGRANT
LIVES LAST YEAR.
I SAW COMPASSION FROM THE
BORDER PATROL.
THE POLICIES OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
CAUSE 2ED SEPARATION OF NEARLY
18,000 FAMILIES PARENTS ARE
PUTTING THEIR CHILDREN IN THE
ARMS OF CRIMINAL CARTELS TO BE
SMUGGLED TO THE UNITED STATES.
31% OF WOMEN GET SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED.
ANOTHER CHILD DROWNED IN THE
RIVER THE OTHER DAY.
THE POLICIES OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL RESULT IN
MORE IMMIGRANT DEATH AND OPEN
BORDERS.
>> THANK YOU FOR THE TIME YOU
GAVE US.
WE HOPE YOU SEE MORE COMPASSION
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE WOULD LOVE TO GET YOU BACK